deux options celle où le camping des
papillons de nuit le lieu idéal pour
retrouver les copains ou sans faire de
nouveau
nous tenterons peut être mais après on
va surtout les campements on va boire un
coup et gi joe cool quoi c'est l'été ça
ja
[Musique]
papillon est faux les papillons mâles et
voilà est toujours de nombreuses
invitations
voumard si pour les uns je ne sais pas à
venir en normandie à salon rendre qu il
venait d style papillon denis
franchement souvent délicat le montage
de la tente
c'est très gros défi en effet oui ah oui
oui beaucoup de gens qui arrivent pour
est on obligé de les aider parce que
voilà ça va il fait beau mais quand il
ya de la pluie du vent rien à plus de 20
quand même mais la sarre la solution
cette année une tente en location et en
carton on se prend pas la tête on vous
montre la tente on la démonte vous en
donne rien ramené et le mieux c'est que
c'est écologique
finalement peu importe la bri la nuit
sera courte